We've been wondering, what is Trump thinking
right now?
Is he thinking is Trump so delusional that
he really thinks he can steal the election
from Joe Biden?
There's a new report from NBC's Peter Alexander,
which is that Trump knows he can't win.
He's putting on a show.
Peter Alexander tweeting yesterday morning,
quote, Trump is very aware there is not a
path to victory, but he believes the 72 million
who voted for him deserve a fight.
So he's battling as a form of theater for
them, a top White House aide tells me.
So I believe this understand the multilevel
scam that this is.
First of all, Trump has Republicans running
all over the country claiming they have a
shot.
Rudy's in Philadelphia, Eric Trump's.
And who the hell knows where?
He's got Secretary of State Mike Pompeo saying
we're going to have a second.
Trump administration press secretary Kayleigh
McEnany saying, you know, this is all it's
all fraud.
Is this all an act where everyone knows it's
fake or does.
Trump think it's fake, but all of his sycophants
believe it's real.
I don't know next layer of the scam, Trump
is raising money on this.
So even if Trump believes this is all theater
in terms of winning, Trump is really raising
real people's money for recounts and for legal
challenges.
And that's the scam because the fine print
of Trump's election fraud fundraising is that
50 percent of the money you give goes not
to lawsuits and recounts.
50 percent of the money you give goes to paying
off Trump's campaign debt.
There are many Trump supporters, many on fixed
incomes, many with low incomes, who really
can't afford to be giving Trump money.
And this is not nanny state stuff where I
think someone should protect them.
The president is scamming them.
It's just the president shouldn't be scamming
them.
That said, it's not about regulation.
If Trump knows he can't win and he realizes
that this is theater, he's raising millions
of dollars from people who potentially can't
afford to be donating to Trump, who are donating
because they think it might help him win.
And Trump himself, according to Peter Alexander,
doesn't think this is going to make a difference.
He's scamming people to pay off his campaign
debt.
Now, I know you know, a fool and their money
are soon parted and all of that stuff.
But there are more and more aides coming forward
now and saying there is not even really the
idea of a plan here.
This is a straight up scam. Trump aides and
advisers and allies have said there's no grand
strategy here.
He'll file a lawsuit, he'll send a tweet,
whatever.
There's no strategy.
And according to The Washington Post, quote,
Asked about Trump's ultimate plan, one senior
administration official chuckled and said,
you're giving everyone too much credit right
now.
They're just lying to people they know.
They're lying to people and they don't care.
And it's not just that they're hurting people
by taking their money.
They're also hurting the United States.
They're hurting our election process.
They're hurting our democracy.
And along the way, he continues to make the
United States a laughing stock.
And he is very clearly I mean, it's a commitment
at this point.
Donald Trump is committed to making the United
States a global laughingstock, not, I would
argue, not just until January 20th when Joe
Biden becomes president, but probably well
beyond that.
And it is all of our, you know, going back
to 2015, 2016, all of our worst fears about
Donald Trump, all of our concerns about how
wacky he might be as president, how disastrous
they were, understated.
We've talked before about this bogus term
Trump derangement syndrome used to dismiss
criticism of the president saying, oh, you
people are so hyperbolic.
Almost no one was hyperbolic enough about
the presidency of Donald Trump.
That's the reality.
It's starting to wrap up and that's a very
good thing.
A little bit later today, I am going to talk
about what can Joe Biden get done if he doesn't
get the Senate, will Trump really run again
in twenty, twenty four?
What's next for the Republican Party?
A lot of very important questions we will
deal with later.
I'm glad you're here.
Follow me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we will be back right after this.